- [Narrator] Behold the mighty mangrove.
Renowned for its toughness
and ability to foster
sensitive marine life,
they play an important
role in tropical ecosystems
all around the world and,
especially, here in Sri Lanka.
Despite their strength, the
mangroves are being destroyed
to make room for commercial
farming operations
and development deals.
But all hope is not lost,
thanks to Sri Lanka's Mangrove Master.
- [Narrator] Douglas has worked formally
doing conservation works since 1992
and recently became the
director of a museum
dedicated to mangrove conservation.
- [Narrator] In addition
to stopping destruction,
part of his conservation work involves
planting mangrove saplings
to replace the trees
that have already been lost.